ich konnte einmal durch den großen bogen
in die antike eintreten ist ein kluger
nachdenklicher nachdenklich machen dafür
dieser zeitreise hieß es geht um die
zerstörung der syrischen stadt palmyra
durch den es im sommer und herbst 2015
und im frühjahr 2017 morgen
es ist zum mittag es ist zum mittag der
islamische staat ist schon längst
realität geworden
auf was wartet ihr den machen was macht
ihr denn nach damals hat der irs die
wichtigsten momente dieser einmaligen
städte zerstört wie sollte ich damals
ahnen dass diese ganze antike lebensraum
weil zu stürzen würden die großen tempel
die wichtigsten bestandteile der großen
colonnaden straße und die grafttherme in
denen die geschlechter der stadt im
zweiten und dritten jahrhundert nach
christus ihre toten begraben hat ich
begann die begriffe weltkulturerbe zu
zweifeln als putins war in palmyra und
hat alle diese elemente noch neben
ursprünglichen zustand aufnehmen können
die vergessenen ruinen von palma waren
einst von sehnsüchtigen europäern
verklärt dann ausgebeutet und
restauriert werden um heute
als wertvolles denkmal in einem kultur
krieg unterzugehen aber sein film
handelt nicht vordringlich von der
trauer um die verlorene antike stätte
ich möchte in diesem film ein
unwiederbringliches bild von palmyra
überliefern eines dass die antike nicht
von der gegenwart wie realen menschen
isoliert die von ihr lebt und wie sie
als ihre heimat liebten und
er zeigt wie zumindest im jahr 2008 der
syrische alltag an dieser hoch
touristischen stelle aussah er spricht
mit händlern
er spricht mit einheimischen
jugendlichen und er zeigt wie sie
umgekehrt auf uns schauen auf die
touristen die damals bei müller noch
reichlich bevölkert haben
[Musik]
mit anderen worten er redet über die
gedankliche und dann auch faktische
aneignungen dieser ruinenstadt durch den
westen durch europa einen film dessen
bilder einen noch lange begleiten und
genau das richtige gegenmittel gegen die
nostalgie die uns gefällt wenn wir an
verschwundene altertümer denken
[Musik]